hey how's going everyone we are back and
we're gonna do some more SDL to work and
just expand the sound of class a little
bit so this is a continuation from the
last video did on my channel which is
part one of this series on SDL I don't
know how far I'm going to go with it
hands-on interest so let me know if
you're interested in seeing more of this
tour sort of thing so what we did last
is let's see we basically got some basic
sound effects playing as many as we want
the more you add the more choices you
have and it just plays them until you in
turn negative one in the console I did
have one small error which I need to
show you guys so when you play a sound
effect if it if the one you choose is
larger than the Bank size then we
actually want to return right here
otherwise it will attempt to play a
sound that doesn't exist and it will
crash fix return fail no crashing stage
commit and push so I think what I'm
gonna go ahead and do here is just tag
tag this one like video one there we go
no push that tag and now let's just
create a new branch here to do our new
work now basically what I want to do
next is add another thing but not just
for sound effects let's go ahead and hit
play on this real quick I want to add
one for music so I have sound effects
here it's like a loaded all three one
zero one and two already so let's try
these out real quick I'm going to start
with two one zero
so those are my sounds that I loaded
from my drop box and if I do one out of
range
it'll just just do nothing until we get
negative one and then the law apparently
say sound out of range and then still
leave okay I see why it's because it
does a
to go through this just based on how we
have our loop even if we put in C
negative one here it attempts to play
the sound effect clears and then it
misses we're exits so if we want
negative one to immediately exit we
could just say like if we do this right
here choice equals equals negative one
we will just well we could either return
or we could break out a while loop with
a break so that way it doesn't attempt
to play a negative one sound so okay few
things here and there we go so now we
want to add other sound not just sound
effects but we want to add music say we
want to add some backward take ourselves
into our our level and of course you
want sound effects to be able to play
and music to be able to play so with
with planes music you want to be able to
pause it resume it and do fade so I
don't think we're gonna add in the fades
but I will cover some basic play and
pause logic well let's see I think we're
just gonna add now we'll just add a
second class SDL - we'll just save music
so I'm just going to add in a music
class and I'm gonna take this
initialization and make it sort of
static that way it doesn't happen over
and over and see right off the bat here
put my class not within this folder come
on visuals - you can someone fix that
please if I right-click on the folder
and then add within a folder why doesn't
it go into the folder it's just such an
obvious thing that was overlooked
alright so we're gonna have a very
similar thing I'm just gonna go ahead
and copy all this and we're gonna get
straight business of like
and of course these are SDL to music and
not sound effects alright so we'll just
keep it going here and we'll one add add
music track
you wanna play music track and we're
also gonna want some other ones like you
pause that's what yours to see me
Annoying controls function that plays or
pauses the music and this one will play
a different music track and instead of
mixed chunks we're gonna have mix music
because those are longer form okay very
well now we're going to have to
initialize all this stuff and like I
said now this initialization that came
from the first one it's gonna be a
little bit awkward now so we're just
going to make a a single initialization
class or maybe we'll even just make it a
yeah I guess a class is good let's do
another class here and we'll call it uh
I guess STL an it I'm trying to think I
could just do I'm probably over
complicating this like we could just
didn't initialize it in our main before
call in these classes but I just kind of
want it to be all encompassing and you
not have to do additional groundwork in
the main so your main you can just like
instantiate a class and then do stuff
right away with it that's my personal
preference let's see here I'm just gonna
call it SD l an it
I guess we're gonna do some logic like
this in front of it we got to have the
class instantiating are the we have to
have this variable available right away
feel like this is gonna just confuse
people but oh well maybe you'll get
something out of it all right so the
sound effects are fine they now just end
it the sound music is the thing we gotta
work up here okay final and vector oh my
god I had all that stuff but we have
anyone use it yet let's just make sure
our new init class works by hitting play
here and build errors what's the error
here music mix is on the line okay Ronny
using that class but okay we got this
exception thrown read access is no
pointer oh yeah so I don't want to check
it against anything we just want to see
if it's no lure not okay so there we go
that's better so it works all right so
it works fine with that initialization
class let's just run again to be sure
and now we want to get the music going
so the music's gonna look very similar
to the sound effects whereas when we
start out we're just going to initialize
it with SDL emit include yeah so we need
to include that so we can so we can do
what we want I don't think we're doing
anything here we're not gonna use this
one it's all going to take care of
itself when we exit the program for now
so we want to add music track little
play music track and we want to play
pause if we instantiate this class
it'll initialize SDL if it needs
so we can we can work that right in here
we got the sound effects already and we
can also do SDL to music now doesn't see
it okay I gotta include it right and
then we can do a very similar thing as
these except we gotta control a few
different things as far as how we're
loading it and we should get we should
grab longer waves of actual music so let
me just find something real quick here
on my drive so we'll have one music
thing there and of course it's not add
sound effect it's add music track now so
that's why that's complaining and looks
like we should use these other slashes
what we can do right off the bat is we
can just play the music play music track
and then we can have a little checker in
here so if we want to add a music track
we gotta take that path and attempt to
load it so we'll do mix music and it's
mix load use it'll be the path if you're
using a stream you'll need Patsy string
and before adding it to our list we want
to check that it is legal so it's not a
null pointer basically then it is good
if it is a null pointer it's bad so if
it's no dude this whole error I'm gonna
need STL log the error do i when is it
what's my data called him sound effect
based him music's almost all musics
musics word is
so there you go it's good to add it if
we hit play in which it'll just attempt
to play the one we're at which is gonna
look good well we want to check her once
again to make sure we're not going off
we're out of range so first of all we'll
just check that it's greater than him
music sighs do you want to just return
I'm not gonna worry about giving them a
message I'm just gonna not do anything
and we'll just attempt to play that mix
play music musics at which and we will
do a negative 1 which is the loop and
there we go so that will play a music
track now we if we want to pause it
we're gonna need a few more variables
we're gonna need a boolean or pause and
play and when we play a new track we'll
set it right away to through alright so
in our play pause logic basically we
want to check if it is playing well okay
so if it's not playing and it's not
paused
then we basically want to play our track
but it should already be playing because
we've hit this play music track to play
a certain one so what we actually want
to look at here is if music is playing
and it's not paused then we want to
pause it and we do that with mix pause
music and it'll just pause the current
one that's playing and we'll say and
pause two equals true at this point
still considered playing it's just
paused so that's the point of the pause
just like I'll see you player you hit
pause it's still considered playing it's
just like stuck at that location to eat
it play again so doesn't lose his track
I guess this should actually be an
else--if so we just want to make sure
it's actually playing so if it's playing
and paused then we just want to unpause
it basically with mix presume music then
we'll say in pause equals false so it
has to be plane and the other else case
is music playing so when we just guest
return and in plane you know it's cannot
be modified despina access to a constant
ago that's the problem so I'm I marked
this disc on so it's not allowed to
change any member variables so that's
that's pretty typical about any
complaint
and look there we go music is playing
[Music]
sound effects play
if we hit P call now we've entered some
kind of loop P like oh it's because
there's an end so when I'm actually
thinking is if it's a character and it
still shouldn't bug it out because when
it sets back to zero it shouldn't care
anymore but apparently it is so I'm not
I'm not gonna question any further here
no still call this an int fine but
instead of switching on P will call the
music something I will just stick with
the integers I don't know how about
eleven enter eleven for now eleven
played and pause the music so there yeah
hit a bunch cause it's out of range so
there we go I know I know it works it's
amazing it's great you want to see the
code check out github thanks for
watching this episode hope you're able
to get music playing okay in your
application using some of the things
that were shown here as you can see it's
pretty efficient you know using did just
as basic logic I'm doing here you could
make your own little sound player or a
little sound playing program so could
you start it so I don't wanna play it
too long because I know she's gonna get
flagged but uh looks to be working
pretty good here so yeah if you want a
better logic choice for do and play
pause feel free I'm aware that this
isn't the best way of doing it but I'm
pretty happy about getting the
initialization set somewhere else that
way it is auto handled no matter which
class we instantiate you only initialize
once with this this sort of method
alright well see you guys in the next
episode keep coding
Peter
you